[Music]
listen do you want to know a secret do
you promise not to tell this is
definitely on Her Majesty is not so
Secret Service but the government might
be about to sign off on a bid that
allows a Chinese telecoms giant to
effectively run much of our 5g network
this is not so much communist Reds under
the bed
there'll be everywhere from our cars to
kitchens and bathrooms to boot was
courtesy of the most questionable of
decisions by Prime Minister Theresa May
there's been one hell of a who why we
done it Rao / precisely who leaked
details of a highly confidential
National Security Council meeting that
discuss this defense secretary Gavin
Williamson even suffered his very own
Skyfall he lost his job as a suspected
culprit what a load of thunder balls
this is a story of massive public
interest that affects the security of
every one of us we've a right to know
and this was a case of journalists doing
what journalists are put on earth to do
put simply this was a license to spill
the beans it wasn't such a serious topic
I mean that was amazing you know there's
a few angles to this special of course
as a broadcaster I agree with you and
it's vital that information like this
gets to the public there's a clear
public interest I think it meets any
threshold when it comes to that test
it's certainly in the public's interest
to know if the Chinese state will have
some form of advantage over the privacy
of our lives especially considering what
they're doing in China now some viewers
may watch the black mirror a TV show
there's an episode about so the social
credit system where a totalitarian state
uses social media to control the lives
of its citizens and punish them for
misbehavior and indeed that's what China
is doing and so it's scary it's scary if
China has a foothold in our tech and in
our country and regarding
I have to wonder what through resumes
thinking as Prime Minister I was saying
to you earlier I think you know the term
lame-duck may not necessarily suffice
because the way she's handled this the
the way that she seems to be going
against intelligence advice in making
this decision I think it would be more
appropriate to describe her as a
drunk-driving doc I think that it is
though there is a question about the
Official Secrets Act and I think that
though whoever leaked this probably did
the country a favor
they probably do need to be disciplined
for another reason and that's the
precedent of the Official Secrets Act
let's get Michele let's get Michele and
just to say Gavin Williamson of course
denied that he's the source of the leak
although he has paid for as I said with
his job the key here Michele is of
course cabinets leak they've always
leaked this is probably the leakiest of
all cabinets but this is the National
Security Council where you would be
allowed to think that you could discuss
the most sensitive details so I still
say it's in the national interest even
though it's a national security do you I
so a cabinet is one thing a colander is
another and I am absolutely fed up with
the politicians letting us down and
betraying trusts not actually doing
their job so if you are on the National
Security Council you have to be able to
maintain confidentiality it's just an
absolute basic and a given because our
safety is in your hands if you're on
that committee so I think it's appalling
that a leak of any nature would come
from that particular committee I think
if there is concerns ie you're getting
into bed with someone that you shouldn't
be getting into in this case this
Chinese cooperation then you you confine
it into that room you have your
conversations you do your role you you
you have your responsibilities and you
push back in the confines of that
environment and make your voice hello
what if you lose well then that's a
different question for a point further
down the line and there should be some
kind of policy and some kind of way of
really of raising your concern as I'm
fed up with Paula Paula Titian as
running to the newspapers every five
minutes is what it feels like in order
to weather
score points whether it's undermining
and I think it's absolutely wrong and if
we think if we look at the Official
Secrets Act for a second yeah and look
at this it's a criminal offence to
obtain or publish any information from a
serving or former member of the security
and intelligence services or from
certain categories of civil servants
where that disclosure would be damaging
there is no public interest of it so
what I would say is this undermines to
me the confidential nature of that
committee and how freely people should
be able to speak in those meetings
without the fear of one of them running
off to the nearest press I'm gonna come
because your journey so I think I know
where you are and I do want to hear it
June I'm interested where you are in
this yeah I'm gonna be very quick and
then now you too Carol and I agree with
you I completely accept Michele and
magics point regarding the Official
Secrets Act but I think we need to make
allowances for whistleblowers and the
question that we should be asking which
is why I have no idea what to resumes
thinking is would the reverse be
possible look the Chinese allow us to
install there 5g I mean I understand
that Westminster Journalism is run by by
leaks and off-the-record briefings I get
bad but this is entirely different this
was the leak from it from a national
security and the problem here is that
what's at stake is the capacity of the
security services to get you know to
give information in secret and for it to
really John Williamson has got form
filiz you know that when he's incoming
he denies it here what he might deny but
you know we were told last night and was
on the news that that resume had
compelling evidence might not be him it
might be someone hid in his office but
what I think I know for a fact and never
even being a journalist and haven't I
got this story I would have absolutely
done it and been happy to have done it
however does this stop me thinking that
the cabinet minister who leaked it
should not only be sacked but should be
prosecuted because had a civil servant
stomach don't notice it Kevin a minute
okay others at the meeting but if there
was a civil servant who done it he
definitely will be prosecuted so why if
it turns out to be Gavin Wilson why not
him though it does behoove us to
remember that many an abuse of human
rights has been committed in the name of
national security and whether that was a
double raid on tanomo
and other places
especially uh behind the specter of
national security being raised to
silence people from critics criticizing
what's being done in the name of our
protection is constantly something that
journalist I think do you security
services have to be able to give a nice
Haislip
I already concede that the leaker should
be punished but I do think there's a
public interest in this knowledge as a
non journalist can I ask you a question
as a journalist so in this situation so
if somebody's leaked from this you know
highly confidential forum to a newspaper
isn't there a law that obligates that
newspaper to disclose the source
ultimately the editor could as you when
you read that note I mean the editor in
the journals of all could face
prosecution you have to weigh up two
things you have to your defense which I
think would whoever has leaked this I
think you would be able to prove this is
in the public interest and that actually
that would allow newspapers believe it
ought to hack to do whatever they like
if it is in the public interest so
that's the measure the other thing you
have to do is national security now the
government is able to serve what's
called a d-- notice which stops
publication but i my question is so we
need to understand who this leak is from
the perspective of confidentiality now
rather than wandering around doing
investigations and all the rest of it
isn't it just as simple as to reason
we're going to the editor of this news
my question alley isn't there a legality
when it comes to something such as this
the severity in a police state I don't
think you can you can't hack for Public
Interest because that's committing a
criminal offense sorry yeah okay but you
can go to you can take other measures
that would allow you if you could
receive somebody knows that you didn't
receive their information source point
on the source point I think there's
another principle at stake here and that
applies to lawyers as well Michelle you
know if you're worried about
intelligence officers having the
confidence in the national security to
be able to speak without their words
being leaked
you've got other systems that play
lawyers need to be able to hear
testimony from the suspect without being
forced to reveal that testimony against
attorney-client privilege journalists
have a similar thing where if you if you
break that taboo if you go into there
and say you've got to give us your
source the entire professional journey
but don't you think don't you think that
this is indicative of the government we
have now this has never happened before
ever to my knowledge anyway and and
there's an identity that we have Teresa
may we have a government charge where we
have a load of ministers and politicians
who think they can do whatever and she
clearly she's lost control of her
cabinet and just one quick point and and
I'm not bringing this back to briggsie I
promise I think you'll agree with me I
do think that you know if we are looking
to leave the EU then surely it makes
sense for us to be giving these sorts of
contracts to British companies so that
we know we're creating jobs in this
country so not just in terms of national
security out of self-interest you were
certainly drunk driving drunk that's
what I'm just pleased it's taken this
long for the B word to be mentioned
fair play to cereza mayor by the way
she's actually shown an element of
leadership for once members of accurate
quickly and firing someone but anyway
coming up next on the pledge I'm saying
we need to support all members of
society
[Music]